so welcome everybody on stream hello
everybody here at the venue uh it's
absolutely great and fantastic to be
back in person
so once upon a time and more specific uh
20 years 23 years ago when I started as
a software engineer there was a legend
out there
a software engineer to whom we all
looked up
and nowadays he's best known for
creating Trello and stack Overflow so
maybe you can only guess who is this so
it's Charles wolsky and Joel was back
then best known for his blog
and his most famous blog post was things
you should never do part one and
actually I never figured out whether
there is a part two so maybe somebody
you know
and
that blog post he named the single word
strategic mistake a software company
organization team or developer can do
and that is rewriting software from
scratch
and that is what we did
for the toast the tech talks test
automation tool a tool downloaded more
than 80 million times a month both
heavily used in the open source
community and by multi-billion Dollar
companies alike
and today I want to tell you the story
of talks and especially about the
rewrite you will learn about the reasons
for the rewrites the planning the ups
and downs and how we finally released it
and most importantly you will learn more
about us the maintainers
so first about me my name is Jurgen Mark
I'm a senior software engineer at
canonical I work at the Launchpad team
so I take care of the build
infrastructure for Ubuntu
and when I introduced to myself here at
the conference somebody was asking hey
Jurgen from now on when I have to
install something a package I virtually
see you every time pressing a button to
improve the download but luckily it's
all automated
so you can always reach out to me on
Twitter or Mastodon and I also have a
Blog but it's not as famous as the one
of Joel I'm one of the maintainers of
talks I'm a PCF fellow and I live in the
Bavarian Forest so the Outreach of the
rain forest and that's possible because
of the new remote work
and actually for canonical that's not
you we are remote first for 19 years
and actually we are hiring we are also
hiring especially in my team we are
looking forward to new Junior positions
so if you want to if you're interested
reach out or have a look at the website
uh now back to talks what is talks so
talks is a test automation tool and what
is that
so in in order to explain that we need
to have a look what usually is done when
you want to test the library and that is
the menu where you create a virtual
environment you build the package you
install the package you install the test
dependencies maybe Pi test and coverage
and then you run the test I'm probably
more like linters and you want to build
documentation but then that's only
for one environment for your local PC
and not you can't test against other
python versions or against the different
framework version and what about your
colleagues they need to duplicate all
the effort and also for CI so of course
yeah you need to duplicate it again and
maybe you have external contributors so
that's pretty tedious right
so there's a better way and with talks
you can create a
configuration file and then you can
specify the python versions and you set
up the test environment and then you
just install talks
for preferable with pipex which is an
awesome tool to have to install python
command line tools and then you just run
it on UPC on CI on your colleagues PCS
and all the contributors
to understand the rewrite we first need
to understand the roots of talks so
talks was created by Holger Creek back
in 2010 so it's already 13 years old and
maybe you're not familiar with that name
but holga also created Pi test
he created Dev pi and Pi Pi not Pi Pi
the package index but Pi Pi the
alternative python implementation
and then sometime past seven years talks
got pretty popular some even called it
the standard in testing and then Bernard
Gabor joined not because he wanted to
become an open source maintainer but out
of necessity he wanted to have some bug
fixes and he wanted some new features
and so it became a maintainer
but soon he noticed that talks was
written with some specific assumptions
so it's only used to create a python
environment not the Honda environment
only on your local system
you can only configure it via docs ini
not Pi projectormal or a pythophile and
it's almost there for to create Source
distributions and not a wheel
and the while you saw the the
configuration first it's pretty small it
can be really long and talks evaluated
it completely eagerly at startup and so
startup was pretty slow
and he noticed that all the changes when
he wanted to change anything of that it
was really hard or even impossible
and obviously when you join a project
what do you do
you rewrite it obviously so
but as you can see they're not started
his first rewrite attempt but he did not
finish it but he learned a valuable
valuable lessons of that
and then just a little bit time after
that Holger quickly left the project and
this is something completely normal
something
healthy for a project when there's some
rotation and when you're not entirely
happy with working on open source or on
this one project just leave it in and
pass it to the next one
and I often get asked why did I create
talks or why did I call it talks and I
was oh it wasn't me it was somebody else
and it's just normal
and soon after that Bernard not noticed
a pattern in the back reports of talks
and a lot of the bug reports actually
were not for talks but for virtual amp
and talks uses virtual amp in the
background to create virtual
environments
and at that time talks uh virtual amp
wasn't really well maintained so we're
not created a contributed a couple of
bug fixes and so on and then eventually
became a maintainer of virtual length
yeah you guessed it what is the next
thing
started rewriting greater length
obviously
and before I tell you how that went uh
just uh
to get this into perspective
at that time I I was a soap maintainer
this is a very old python-back framework
and at that time we migrated from python
2 to Python 3 and that for over 300
packages and I was completely lost I
created so many virtual environments I
cope with back and forth code and
and remember I was like 10 years in or
more than 10 years in the industry and I
didn't know how to do this so I asked my
fellow maintainers and hey we just used
stocks and that's the way when I came to
to know about talks so
I'm super happy that everybody is here
that you exchange information and that's
the way to go forward and to learn about
tools and don't wait 10 years
then the resolution of the question uh
with the virtual library was successful
uh we are not created a very
entertaining and technically deep dive
talk of it you should watch it
and
soon after that only one week he
announced Talk's second edition rewrite
on Twitter
and a little bit later he created the
first commit
and then
something special there was something
special he started streaming the rewrite
on talks on on Twitch
and I got to know that on on Twitter and
imagine back then I was the single
python Dev in a small company and
everything I needed to learn I learned
from books or something else and now
there was this super experienced
developer
working on the Tula love and completely
rewriting from scratch streaming live he
shared his thoughts about the design the
architecture and I was really sucked
into this talk thing after that
I started answering talks questions on
stack Overflow that's my usual thing
when I wanted to learn a new tool I just
answer other people's questions
and soon afterwards I created a talk
because back then I was super confused
how do I should I run Mylanta do I run
it with vs code or via the command line
or via talks or via pre-commit and it
took a while but then it clicked and I
created a talk to to share my knowledge
I then started contributing to
discussions and GitHub issues
and then Bernard announced talks for
Alpha 2 and he also asked the users to
test it
so I tested it for my personal project
for my 10 also work projects and then I
remembered I'm a contributor to soap and
we have 300 repositories and all of them
are using talks
so I thought about how can the test
talks against all those 300 repositories
and I didn't want to do this manually so
I used a tool called oripus
and with this tool you can clone a
complete organization from GitHub menu
repositories at scale but you cannot run
arbitrary tools against it
and tested it against all 300
repositories
I did not say it was successful so
there were only 22 percent of the
repositories actually worked with the
new talks version
so I reached out to Bernard and told him
that and he had a perfect answer on that
so a 22 success is not a great news but
on the plus side it seems if you fix
soap we should be in a decent place and
that's the optimism we need here
meanwhile we also got some feedback on
Twitter on the rewrite
especially as Bernard announced that
that the plug-in system will be
incompatible from talks 3.4
and Oliver back then also a maintainer
of talks asked other people with the
Torches and the pit Forks at the gates
already
and spoiler they were not yet
but we come back to that later
and then something nice happened jock
joined the uh the issue tracker had a
problem and I helped solve it she's
unfortunately no longer here and I think
that's something important a message I
want to do
say here that um
usually we only get bug reports or angry
people or they want to have features or
they want to have you know that's 500
lines a conflict file debugged for the
company
uh so if you use open source software
reach out to them and they think thank
you
and then I created my first serious pull
request for talks about the issues I
reported
and I was really into that and I created
pull request of the pull request and
soon after that when I announced me as a
talks maintainer
I did not want to rewrite it then
again
and and I I don't know whether can you
imagine that I love the the tool and it
was you know so upward so high and now I
became the maintainer of it and this was
so amazing for me and only later I
realized that there's a lot of work for
free
so I also created a talk about testing
the pre-release against the soap at soap
scale which is also a pattern that we
try to spread the word about the rewrite
because we anticipated there will be
some issues
and but not around also talks for a
rewrite at pycon us
and then yeah life happened
imagine now at the end of 2021 we're
already one and a half year into the
rewrite
and then but not move to the U.S and you
don't do this on a weekend right
I built a house for my family and I also
joined canonically and I certainly
wanted to you know do a good job there
so
basically
one and a half year into the rewrite we
pause the rewrite almost for a year
because we had no time and you can
imagine that the people got angry
and back to the Torches and the
Pittsburghs
but instead of torches they used pipes
and
we got some messages like this one just
release it that multi rewrite never
seems to reach General availability if
this was been a business it would be
being banked one long time ago
and first I thought oh my such a
but then I thought oh what about if
they're right
what about if you do something wrong
and then again Bernard stepped up and
gave a great answer
such a major release will ultimately
break a lot of people and we need
maintain availability to help those
users and address their concerns and so
it's about the users and not about the
maintainers
and then something remarkable happened
I've never seen before in my career we
got a bug report on talks on the talks
tracker that in the pilip
Library which is a dependency of talks
there's a vulnerability
and the SVN module we didn't even use so
well okay it is like that but we can't
do much about that
but then there are tools like pip audit
and safety which check the open source
supply chain and they reported as an
error and then for a lot of people the
CI broke
what do we do well we had no chance to
do a lot so we recommend recommended
them to whitelist this vulnerability
because well it's not affecting talks
but this was only part one
because the same people or maybe some
other people also reported the
vulnerability against Pi test
because Pi test is also using that
Library
and then the pi test people which is
super familiar and super widespread
program so I thought hey what can we do
and they did something different
they rendered pilip for version seven
and when it is when you basically take
the source code of a library and you put
it in your own source code they left out
SBN and a couple of other things they
didn't need and it worked out pretty
well for pi test
but they rendered pilip in a very
special way now the vendor pilot Shadows
the installed pilip
and talks was trying to import from the
pilot but from the vendor pilot and when
the pilot was only partial so talks
broke because there was a missing import
and this was a serious mess for us
because the combination of toxin pie
test is super widespread but we still
did not have the capacity to do anything
right
and then something beautiful happened
sorenspenera announced to be able to
work a full week on talks 4. and he's a
long-term friend of talks and a plug-in
maintainer and at the end it was not a
full week but it really gave a new
momentum and so we finally moved it over
the finish line
only three years later after we started
basically
and guess what happened
so we had lots of regressions we had
lots of complaints but on the plus side
we also had lots of contributions almost
50 50 contributors knew and one of them
became eventually also a talks
maintainer and we got some some praise
which is always nice
so let's think about why did we get so
many regressions
and there is harem's Law and it says
with a sufficient number of users of an
API it doesn't matter what you promise
in the contract all observable behaviors
of your system will be depended on by
somebody
and virtually we got bug reports for
things we didn't even know that talks is
able to do but now we know
and at that time I was a little bit
frustrated
because whenever I contribute to talks
I take away the time for my family and
spending time with my kids
and anyway the people got angry
and
back then I read the blog post and it's
called I'm not your supplier and that
blog post really resonated with me
and
because you know we offer that for free
it's about anybody to use it or to leave
it certainly we don't want to break you
but we have restrictions and we do this
in our spare time so this was really a
great blog post and some cheer up
and I don't want to bore you with the
highlights of the release
but when you have a close look at that
list
and when you compare it to what Bernard
identified as the issues at the
beginning we pretty much reached that
what we wanted to do so we are able to
continue to develop and extend talks and
what is ever necessary for the future
and how is this possible we use better
abstractions before it was you know
one or two or three files with a lot of
mixed responsibilities and now we had a
complex uh sub package for configuration
management execute for command execution
and on
and this was not entirely clear from the
beginning but it evolved over time
and after the rewrite we sat together
and we thought hey what to do well so we
have an automated test suite and this is
given you need to do this you have to do
this we announced the rewrite on all
channels but don't think people really
test other versions a couple of did
thanks for that after release we sticked
around to help the people migrating and
Unbreak their CI we kept a legacy Branch
so in case we needed to release an old
do a new release of the old version we
kept the old documentation
and yeah we kept the talks free branch
so we also sat down together and I
thought what could have we done better
and this sounds
this sounds odd or maybe arrogant so let
me rephrase it
we could definitely nothing better given
the resources that's just life we are
not full-time employees of talks
and
we also have a couple of Lessons Learned
you need to have a plan
you need to test a lot
you need to be available Post Release
you need to prepare for bug fixes in the
upcoming months after the release
be ready to re-evaluate everything
from the ground up
and be nice but set boundaries
and obviously we learned that Legends
are not always right
so thank you very much for attending my
talk thanks to the organizers for having
me and thanks for canonical to send me
here
[Applause]
you were very fast
yes still 10 10 minutes you told me to
speed up
so but we already already have two
questions so you can still ask questions
um also online
um I will read the first one and you
mentioned pipe project Tamil in the
beginning of the talk why is there still
only Legacy support for Pi Project
tomorrow included in talks4
yeah because of time restrictions that's
that's it we
previously with talks 3 it was not
possible or almost not possible to edit
now we as I showed you there we have the
right abstractions in place so anybody
can contribute we are currently you know
it was pretty stressful with the talks
Theory right and we're currently a
little bit in maintenance mode and
waiting for you know settle everything
that everything settles down and we are
currently not available for
new feature requests or for working on
only feature requests we are super happy
to onboard new people
and to help people and to review much
proposals but we need a couple a little
bit of rest after the rewrite
it came very fast fast was the questions
question what's your opinion on Knox
uh knocks the developers of Knox are our
friends so basically for those who don't
know this talks and there's knocks and
basically that both tools do similar
things or the same things like running
tests or whatever things again multiple
uh python versions and managing virtual
environments and the main difference
currently is that nox uses a python file
to uh for configuration so you can do
whatever you want it's maybe a little
bit more mightier but it's also you need
to take care of what you put in
because you know compared to the setup
tools they went away from having python
as a configuration configuration
language but what you certainly can use
talks with your friends I'm currently
reviewing a book of one of the Knox
authors so we are really close friends
and we are not competitors it's just
getting better with two uh two projects
in the field and
they even have an importer so I hope you
don't want to move from talks to Knox
but they have a talks importer
maybe I shouldn't have said that
one of the most highest rated comments
is nice job which is not a question but
thank you
um the next one is what is the main
advantage of using talks over CI
Solutions like GitHub actions and Matrix
strategy okay so basically it's not an
either or
um
when you use talks you can use it
everywhere locally on your machine on
your other machine on your employer your
colleagues machines on whatever and also
on CI so my strategy usually is I create
a local talks file I can run all the
tests against all the different python
versions or combinations or whatever we
we want to test against and then I also
use talks in GitHub actions so basically
I install talks and GitHub actions and
use the configuration file to to run it
and so it's not an either or so it's a
perfect solution to use both together
and that's what the one talk I mentioned
earlier is about how to combine linters
locally development and running things
in CI because otherwise you test
something locally then you need to
completely build a matrix online and
basically talks can create matrixes
already so you don't need GitHub actions
for that and imagine that you develop
something then you you run maybe only
the one python version test locally and
you push it to CI and it breaks
after 10 minutes 20 minutes or whatever
and maybe all your colleagues get an
email so I want to make sure my code
Works before I push it
okay I will just go like with the
highest rated okay and so the next one
is what did you learn joining as a
maintainer and what you really
recommended for someone with this family
and a full-time job
okay
so
I think in my career which is pretty
long meanwhile the first
major thing was going to my first pycon
in 2017 where I met Miro that was
amazing for my career informal
development and the second and most
important thing was joining an open
source project because back then I was a
developer the loan developer or single
developer in a small company and I had
not a lot of exchange with other
developers and working on open source
projects was like working with the world
class software engineers and getting
reviews for free and giving something
back so it was one of the best decisions
but it was not like
how I want to contribute to that it just
evolved I could not say like oh I like
Libby office let's contribute to it I
couldn't do that it's like out of a
necessity that you just
and and you know that's about it and how
do I manage that with my family
I think it's super important that you
talk with your employer
that they get time during your work time
to work on open source projects
especially when you use it at the
company but also you could uh just
asking for for personal development and
I think that's that's the key when when
talks 4 was released in the internal
canonical channels there was a lot of oh
my God my pipeline is broken whatever
and I certainly try to help them but I
also try to help them with other Python
toolings and I think uh that's important
so don't only do that in your spare time
that's the key
advice
and
people asking how they could contrib
help contribute as like yeah how they
can help uh directly to talks I guess so
the easiest way or the best way is to
have a look at the issue tracker
go through the or maybe let that's the
the standard answer have a look at the
issue check uh have a look at some easy
tasks but the first thing would be try
to use talks and if you feel the
documentation is really good enough and
that's what I do when I use other
projects I just set up a test or try the
tutorials and like in 90 no not in the
pi data popular thing but in that area
where I contribute uh 90 of the
documentation is outdated and doesn't
work and the examples doesn't work and
this is my first contribution to a new
project and then I already see whether
the maintainers erect but sometimes
they're unmaintained I think that that's
the first thing and if you feel
comfortable have a look at the issue
tracker or just uh talk to us if we are
on Discord
discord.gg talks you can always reach
out to us and
I think after the rewrite taxes it's
still
uh not the easiest project to contribute
but we have really good abstraction so
it's way easier than before
some people are interested in the
questions whether the fix would have
been possible without complete rewrite
the the fix to the the first problems we
have like the the five problems they're
not identified at the beginning that
would be super super hard or almost
impossible they were open back reports
for five years or something like that
and it was just too massive to
to act on that it was all always like
you know on building on top a little bit
but the foundation was not correct and
when this uh refers to the one thing
about the pilot
maybe it would have been possible but
we're already very close to the finish
line and I'm super happy that we did it
like that
and then
another maintenance okay actually we did
not yet and a full disclaimer currently
I think I get 43 Euros a month from
some
sponsorship or basically some companies
can pay open source maintainers or
products they use and
we have not
put a lot of effort in that yet
and maybe that's a way but funding is
not we all have good Developer jobs so
it's not uh the number one priority it's
certainly nice to have some compensation
when I tell my wife sometimes I I will
sit down on Friday afternoon or Friday
nights to work on talks but
from a maintainership here a
maintainership perspective I think we
are healthy we are now free maintainers
that's certainly not comparable to the
big Pi data project or something like
that but we are open to new contributors
and new maintainers so if you want to
try it out and uh just go for it
[Music]
it's the same questions like python free
and what about python 4 and I hope it
will never arrive because it broke so
many things
thank you
[Applause]